[Music]
happy holidays everyone
this time of celebration comes once a
year so do our awesome new holiday items
of course you made sure to be good all
year round
make sure you save some bucks to get
yourself the gift
that you most surely deserve make it to
the top of the leaderboards and you'll
get some gold
frankincense and mirror or their in-game
equivalent
and may your winter be as fun as winter
can be
[Music]
today is a very special day we're gonna
get him a beehive well i'm gonna get it
i read a comment you don't need
you don't need self-touch i get it i get
it
last episode we found jurgen and we
found a saddle
and we found wheat we're ready we're
ready to flip and do this
i'll be right back i'll be right back
break it down no
where the hell are the cows apparently
they need bait uh
you guys need just die just die
just die thank you
what are you what are you afraid of
nothing to be afraid of little one
here i'll make more parents don't worry
a lot of y'all don't know this but you
can actually
oh god damn it a lot of y'all don't know
this
a little pro tip
you can use eight partners to says
that's what i'm talking about
all right when i'm back we're gonna have
a new friend for you
i'm so ready this is gonna be so awesome
oh almost forgot the hey and i
say hi do i not have more i have a bunch
of bone me
oh i can left click oh you guys they
didn't know that you can left click bone
me i don't know
okay this could you should give me a
frick ton
no what's hurting me oh my god i'm
poisoned
how did you get in here how
i built the fortress you're so dead
why am i gonna die am i go i'm fine
okay you
little child where are you gonna run
dumb so for jurgen to ride with me i
need to make the ceiling taller
stop it stop ed where did you come from
where did you go gosh
okay all right don't hurt me don't hurt
me
don't hurt me don't hurt me
all right here we go on my swedish
engineered bridge
very errol pigskull they all died
the safest bridge of all time right here
all right we got to make this taller is
it three blocks for a horse
or is it four oh bro bro
come here little child everybody
stupid child you're so dumb
[Laughter]
so dumb oh another child
oh he's crying i'm really his lost
friend this is so sad
oh they're both dead i feel nothing
nothing x in the chat for first
pickaxe all right hopefully it's on
night and rain
how about that guys good thing i i came
prepared right
all right i'm going to my camp i am not
dying before jurgen smergen
are there no moms there they are
so beautiful
all right i gotta set up for a small
house here
it's beautiful
you're good i'm coming
why jurgen why you're again
there you are he loves
why you're get you
look at me you're again don't you
remember me
the rain stopped eat it
eat it you love me now
[Music]
dude you're a greedy ass [ __ ] what the
[ __ ]
he kicked me off but i love you
[Applause]
hey yes yes
you're getting smart again forever
it happened
we're back together my man while we're
totally matching too
holy flipping small dude
yes they said it couldn't be done
but i did it
there's the village i wasn't crazy oh my
black yard against skippy dee puppity
poopity poopy
what's up fellow villagers it's me
pewdiepie
ooh trade me yeah i'll take some money
yo
hey did you know you can have eight
furnaces you don't have that
hey sorry i'm sorry
they have beds dude yo are you telling
me i can buy pants right now
cats oh my god
this is too much they're so rich
little baby do they get mad if i kill
baby
it's so tiny what is it gonna do tell
anyone
let's steal one of their beds actually
now we can actually like
go around and explore stuff gold
what what is this you can stay there my
man
oh golden ho that's it all right fine
i mean i'll take it kind of garbage but
i take it
i can't mine it i have i can't even mine
it
dang it let's not hit that guy because i
know what it will happen
maybe i should migrate somewhere
oh it's dangerous ah you gotta be
careful here again
no sven to be found
[Music]
only sadness hey at least i have your
again right now
i'll take you this is great
oh god i don't have a sword left okay
we're gonna make it back here again it's
getting dark
say bye to your puppy because we ain't
never going back here
oh god i've done this before oh god i
just realized
i tried this once before
[Music]
okay he did he did he's fine he's fine
he's fine he's fine he's fine he's fine
is fine he's fine he's fine he's fine
he's fine it's fine
yes yes
you did it i'm so proud of you jurgen
smergen
can you go in holes he's too fat dude oh
[ __ ] he's too fat
oh my god i got them oh my god it's
going to take ages dude
oh jurgen we're in a pickle now
oh he's following me because he loved me
so much
yes you're so much better than
but don't tell them okay
i got a bad feeling about this okay this
works
careful i know you're a little white
here
oh god jurgen do not fall in that lava
cheese louise on my sleepy peeps
here again here again
you're again you're getting right now
oh don't scare me you're crazy dangerous
here
don't talk to the pigs they're crazy
okay careful
careful careful okay okay we're good
don't talk to the piggies and especially
not the children is this too
are you too fat no he's good okay we're
good
oh this is a problem this is a real
picaroo
[Music]
horses do not belong in the nether
uh do not go anywhere you're again
and i mean anywhere
i actually unironically need these
this is so bad
why didn't i just prep yeah i get no i'm
gonna make it home boy
we're gonna make a homeboy we're gonna
make it we're gonna make it
out oh my god he left stop dude i know
you're scared but it's okay
it's okay maybe it's quicker if i go on
top over here
like where does this go it's a little
dangerous
this is actually very dangerous it's
gotta land on the right angle mjorgan do
you see it
run run you are gonna run like the wing
okay we just gotta make it through here
you can do it just jump
you train your whole life for this i
gotta
eat there you go all right parkour
parkour parkour parkour
he's wearing gold and he's cool there we
go there it is
we made it he's wearing gold and he's
with me
i'm choking parkour
okay okay please please
boy yeah boy
oh you're gonna get the best home of all
time here again the best of the best
the finest of the finest the greatest
house of all time you're again no no no
you love me
you love me no one else yeah boy
unfortunately i'm a little poor so you
stay in here for now
okay cool yeah
that's what i'm talking about man
hardcore is so easy unbelievable
all right oh he uh
he he he's about to shoot himself
okay campfire boom
so i read you don't need self touch
you just have to place a campfire with
two blocks underneath
you're getting number four ytr again
it's time
ow all right let's find a beehive right
i don't know why i love saying beehive
yeah you're again tell me if you see one
no parkour parkour
damn you're really bad at parkour we
gotta this is a problem
parkour there were so many beehives here
i swear
careful now jurgen porgan don't worry
you're safe with me nothing bad has ever
happened to my friends
oh there's a b that's good that's good
news okay that means there has to be a
beehive here somewhere
yes i found your home i found your home
mr b all right you can stay there
don't talk to the oh dude that [ __ ]
oh no i'm gonna die i'm gonna die from a
[ __ ] bee
oh we're okay [ __ ] i need soul touch
dumb kids okay maybe now we can explore
a little bit
there's another b could that be another
beehive
maybe yes yes i'm running on cyberpunk
quality
we're going in an adventure here against
american what's that
why does it look like a castle over
there there's a village
i was right oh this is perfect we can
seek refuge over the night here jurgen
bed please oh books nice
bed please oh get out
my bed idiot oh my god they're so poor
who made you this poor okay let's take
the books because then i can make my
enchanting better right
hey man oh a compass that might be
useful
car that's mine now oh yeah i need this
parkour bells
yes oh it's way bigger than i thought
okay
oh look you got friends here
okay stay here jugging it's like
dropping up your child light
the ball pay oh a child
very well whoa big house
rich people rich people
should i i really shouldn't shouldn't i
don't dodge it again don't tell jurgen
sorry great you're getting drowned
forgot how useless oh my god you're
gonna breathe please
jurgen surface whoa we got another
temple
hell yeah
yeah baby yeah baby
[Music]
i got diamond oh no oh there you are
don't do me like that man look you can
see my house from here
what the hell happened here it's only
one p
one p all right we're going back home
to my beautiful house my god it's
gorgeous oh god it's really dark
you snake oh you're sleeping with me
tonight here again
oh
oh my god dude i am so let's sleep
oh my gosh
literally dude my house
sucks all right since you're kidding
yourself
at least i can make it a little nicer in
here right
no come on
come back come back in
bro bro trust me there's nothing out
there there's nothing good out there
[Music]
oh god i forgot forgot how annoying he
is
my god oh my god
all right ah
stay there i need to make this nicer
it's so ugly
[Music]
[Applause]
oh at least was safe oh my god
no i was making it so nice for uh
all the glass
i hate them i have been building
for the last hours i've been in meetings
and i've just been like yeah
yeah yeah
all right here it is there it is you
like it
he loves it yeah look at this
perfect system of organization
my god once i i was just gonna put a
couple chests and they kept going
and kept going and going and going
look how many furnaces we have 10
furnaces
yeah oh you're so happy i know
i know your ass is a problem we're
working on it got this
lovely view right
in here my beautiful bedroom built in
bed
swimming pool it's whatever i can splash
splash i was going to cover this hole in
glass
so that can have a little outdoor area
i'm so tired of building i i'm not i'm
sorry
enough enough building i'm done next
time next time i'll do it maybe i'll do
like a
building live stream or some [ __ ] but
yeah now it feels
like a real play through put fences so
this place is safe
put a safety water pool in case i fall
because i'm not dying
yard against has this beautiful all
right well i'm it's still a work in
progress
but yeah that's where we're at um uh i'm
very pleased
it's freaking time they love it
look how much they love it they
absolutely they love each other
that's your guys lisa what are you doing
what are you doing idiots
you fools so honestly i don't get how
anyone can ever die
in minecraft we're gonna defeat the
ender dragon so we're gonna have to
start looking in the nether
uh for some ender pearls i'll do that
next episode i have something else in
mind right now hey
oh god the house is so big now i never
know where he is oh god no
did he escape
oh i hear him i
hear him where is he
all right i want to make some
bookshelves and we're going to enchant
some stuff because we need to be ready
for what's about to come hey look at he
absolutely
loves the storage system incredible he
says
yes cool i think that's it
you know what we're going all out
blasting
oh sword sword you cannot afford
my diamond sword it's happening
at last what do we got what level 30
fine unbreaking two can i do it again
no that's it that's all i get i feel
like uh
it's starting to lose it a little bit oh
yeah i have a bunch of
golden arrows which i don't know what
they do but i have them so i'm gonna
keep them
we are ready ready as can be
if i don't come back yeah you're screwed
you're just screwed
don't worry i can't die too strong we're
going in
yeah again number four if i don't make
it back
feel free to kill the cows
oh god what are you doing here are you
gonna kill him oh this is so awkward
bro kill him they're not going for me
right
yeah hey don't touch my door
oh the child oh little child let's try
it
oh oh no did you mommy die
that sucks
oh let's be careful
i'm going this
god damn i still suck dude
okay the bow man the bow
he struck from the trees he's friend of
the beast
oh it's night and i don't have a bed
fine there's a village nearby we're fine
oh geez
bed oh apples oh look a little cat
oh get out of my bed
you can look you can touch don't look
wait
uh yo cat dropped some stuff
look what the cat dragged in i don't
care what anyone says
i am ready slime
for real this time cue that epic music
you're gonna shoot your friend you dumb
i just need to kill the guy with a
banner right
okay that's it guys don't follow me
okay so like oh here we go maybe i
should have prepared a little bit
oh god guys oh they're
they're shooting each other it's fine
they keep shooting each other dude
maybe if i build him in that would buy
me some time right
oh god i could actually die
stop there we go
okay how does he get up
he hurt himself dude
all right you need to go in the pit
stay there we need to set up a perimeter
no no don't kill him don't kill him
build fast felix that's right from the
trees i'm friends with the bees
hey oh it continues
oh geez it begins
oh god
dude we're so funny bro you are so dead
you better keep that door closed
okay okay okay we're good we're good
we're gonna do that in the next episode
thanks for all the support on the market
series i love playing this game for you
guys
bro smash like subscribe
yes huge thank you to everyone for
supporting the arcade indiegogo campaign
it was a huge success to say the least
look at this thing
it's beautiful now as a popular demand
this thing now works with pc games top
pc games
i'm talking call of duty doom gotta try
this baby on doom
pub g valorent you name it
okay we don't have every game but a ton
of games so the blaster now works with
geforce now which is very cool
it also works with pc it has a ton of
library of android games
it's just a new way to play we're
bringing it to you so
the product is now available at
arcade.games
the website itself is very cool check it
out
honestly but you also get ten dollars
off if you enter the code
pewdiepie to get one of these bad boys
so yeah link is in the description
check it out